emotional scenes at the garandi family
their son 17 year old sinha is one of
five people
killed during anti-government protests
in charge on tuesday
his family says he was only a spectator
watching a confrontation between
demonstrators
and security forces in the capital in
germany
shots rang out a bullet broke his arm
and then it went through his stomach
as he fell gas canisters were also fired
into the crowds he was rushed to
hospital and that's where he died
they killed my brother and they may as
well have just killed me too
dozens were arrested during the protest
many of whom say they were just
bystanders
i was waiting for a motorbike suddenly
two soldiers appeared and arrested me
they searched me and took my phone and a
bottle of water they said the bottle of
water was a sign i was a protester
they beat me up and dumped me and then i
was beaten up again
after questioning i was handed to
another group where i had even more
severe beatings
the crackdown on demonstrators has
prompted international condemnation and
calls for investigations
although the protest organizers say they
will keep up the demonstrations
tuesday's crackdown by the military has
forced protesters of the streets
the city appears to be calm for now with
most shops and markets open
but the excessive use of force has grown
criticism from child's allies
including france
chad is now facing an uncertain future
its long-time president
idris derby was killed last week during
fighting with rebels in the north
according to the military the same
rebels were threatened to march
on the capital immediately after his
death
his son general mohammad debi was
announced as his successor
the constitution was suspended and the
military council has said
a move strongly rejected by the
opposition here
but the violence that followed the
elections in early april and the
protests that came after the military
takeover
have further divided the country chart's
new military leader
has promised to start a national
dialogue to unite chadians
but it's not clear if his promise is
enough to end the latest cycle of
violence
in a country with a history of rebellion
tribal conflicts
and military interventions ahmadi ruiz
gemini